[Musique]
avec l'invention de l'électricité
on a perdu 400 bilan de savoie
recueillir sur le feu qu'à cela ne
tienne le chef et guide de plein air
françois-xavier blot nous partagent ces
trucs parce qu'on parle de cuisson sur
le feu mais d'alphonse et c'est pas du
fait qu'on cherche de la chaleur sont
compare par exemple avec un four à
l'intérieur du rake 350 il va me
paraître ministre ampera tueur le doigt
pour reproduire ça et c'est vraiment
tout de bois votre permettre de dérivés
les bois durs comme l'érable ou le
bouleau jaune sont à privilégier
ça dégage une bonne chaleur et ça fait
deux très bonne braise qui peuvent se
maintenir longtemps
papier ou eux-mêmes écorce de bouleau
blanc et qui prend à chacun de trouver
un peu à gauche à droite ont construit
autour de ce type il dit c'est juste
simplement accéléré et aérer la flamme
c'est selon qu'est ce que je veux faire
donc cuisson selon la quantité ou le
thym belge va mettre le volume de bois
tout de suite parce que chez kipré pont
en rajouter parce que son genre faire
des flammes moi je veux juste ma bresse
une fois on à la braise on peut espérer
avoir combien de temps de cuisson mon
avis le charbon pour 45 minutes une
première technique de cuisson à la
plancha
celui d'avoir la bonne température coule
un peu d'eau sur la planche c'est pas
mal bans et on veut une eau qui va
perdre les qui éclabousse et laudun
coule donc va s'évaporer quasiment
instantanément
puissant la plainte sur une cuisson par
contre entre et sion ont saisi sur feu
vif en tout 1 royal est à peu près 2 3
minutes par côté on veut son rosé
l'intérieur et puis ça se fait vertement
de cette étincelle eu sept petites
minutes qui c'est bon si on pense qu'ils
manquent depuis son lancement en tout un
peu court et a saisi le peut
y en at il trop tard et à temps plein
temps normale ce lundi que la cuisson à
bien bonne
les bleus finissent 2
[Musique]
on peut tous et cuir directement sur la
braise
l'idée de la papillote c'est aussi une
ouverture protégée l'aliment qui est fin
parce que tu vois le mettre dans le feu
directement en pleine valeur parce que
c'est quand même des légumes
fac à vérifier qu'il a offert à mesure
ça va évoluer je venais de tourner
[Musique]
et toi un lac
parce que c'est l'été on se permet des
maïs facile de cuir des maïs suffit de
les faire tremper de ramper nus dans
l'eau pour éviter que les feuilles brûle
l'eau qui va s'évaporer pour créer cette
cuisson un peu et tu es faut évidemment
un garde un oeil le sur les maïs qui
sont directement dans le feu menaçait
d'y mettre le plus loin possible à la
flandre
dans les données sur la braise qui on
les tourne régulièrement ça prend un
petit peu d'attention pour éviter que ça
dure trop
pour préparer des mijotés on utilise une
cocotte en fonte
[Musique]
nouvelle à fond pendant quelques minutes
est patent à peu près 4 5 cm de haut le
plus haut c'est bien quasiment sur la
surface au poc soit trop puissant donc
l'or conséquemment je pourrais peut-être
levé un peu le rendu soit 20 soit pierre
de mépris ou autre chose
hélas vu que c'est un pleuvait ganva
matabiau légumes
et je peux jouer le tube d'un dirais
qu'en périphérie avec ce jour la chaleur
qui est importante à contrôler
[Musique]
on peut aussi utiliser une plaque à
pizza ou une roche plate trouvé en forêt
avec les plaques avec les plaques c'est
important de l'es8 pourquoi parce que la
puissance de feu et lola éviter que ça
craque il faut réviser on a ressorti nos
viandes au préalable pour les tempes et
avec qui on veut éviter un gros choc
thermique
que j'imaginais ville patrick puy du
roman bonjour une coloration d'à peu
près un demi centimètre sur les côtés
dont ça va être notre indice avant de
retourner quand même ça fonctionne bien
les pierres pour cuire le soin les
industriels où la nature est
similaire car là c'est intéressant quand
là dessus parce que ça
et l'on peut accompagner cinq des plus
heureux maintenant on va juste et une
autre qu'on a me voilà soit avec une
attention particulière on a retourné
un peu hâtivement régulière
la coloration jeune allemand
m quel festin moi je compte du résultat
ouais et 2d du pire donc on voit là la
clé laquelle
l'accent est parfaite on vous les médias
me saigne et on a mis en scène y
enterrer uzi et colorée au sens bien
bien qu on tient notre maputo fut
trouvée gagne
inspiration japonaise
[Musique]
sûrement bien champignons weiss pommes
de terre soient tous sont deux parties
semblent dans les timings puis on est
arrivé ces présentations rouge puis tous
ceux d'entre eux qui est plein de
potentiel je te dis aujourd'hui tu viens
quand tu veux même si c'est pas chez
nous